in the days and hours before you were
released how did you feel
um thank you very much for having me
it's
going back to this time is extremely
hard
you
because of course you feel isolated you
feel alone but you're also fully aware
that you are a pawn as part of a much
wider um
much wider dynamic and threat
you don't get too much ahead of yourself
um but it's
yeah it's incredibly tense
i'm sure um i wonder if you could remind
us as much as you want to um what
happened to you
sure so i i was undertaking research
fieldwork in the united arab emirates
and i was then detained when trying to
leave the country and i was held for
seven months
in solitary confinement in abu dhabi
i was forced
to take medication
i was i was held to you know
interrogations for 14 15 hours
by myself i was forced
to to confess to being a member of the
british intelligence
uh spying on behalf of of the uk in the
uae um this of course was was entirely
false um
i was denied access to a lawyer i didn't
see anyone for for months
i was threatened you know with physical
harm the
emiratis threatened to take me abroad to
an overseas military base in yemen
they threatened my family
and it was
you know as extremely difficult time
because you were entirely isolated
you're entirely alone
and
this is this is being done deliberately
against you the emiratis knew exactly
what they were doing
um you are there as a
as a pawn
but there has to be a degree of
responsibility both in my case and also
and nazinen's case towards
the uk government
you know what is the uk government
why did they take so long to respond
why did the former foreign secretary
boris johnson
you know say
you know
inaccurately that she was working on
behalf of the british council to teach
journalists
he deliberately
and you know inexcusably
contributed to to her condition
that learned the fact that you know in
both our cases and many others
there is a there's a failure of british
policy to to help protect british
citizens abroad
um
yeah i'm sure that the prime minister
now prime minister would say that he
didn't deliberately um do that he
certainly misspoke and it certainly um
caused significant hardship a continuing
hardship for nazanin hopefully she will
be
home very soon we're still waiting to
hear the latest news on that but she is
ever hopeful um when you get home
you have to start to process don't you
what has happened to you do you still
struggle with that
100
this is a process of of constant repair
these injuries these mental injuries are
not
uh like breaking a leg
you you do still have those mental scars
those emotional scars when you are
trying to
on a daily basis
get to a degree of of of stability and
normality it's you have a daily struggle
from
from leaving your house
to interacting with your your with your
family
um
you know maintaining those relationships
and
i i got help from an organization called
freedom from torture and an extremely
good charity in london providing people
in in cases such as my own
um
it's it's a it's a constant process but
you always have to accept that
there is a there is a new reality in
your life and it's not just for yourself
it's also for your family members the
people around you there are lessons to
be learned
um everyone has to everyone has a
different perspective and a different
experience of what happened
so it'll be extremely difficult for
nezunan to to be able to to return
and to readjust
but also the same for her family um
you know that they've spent all this
time being in a constant state of threat
of of worry of of anxiety
um and having her back will be extremely
difficult you know
to reintegrate um
the times past
i'm sure that's true matthew thank you
so much i'm so sorry that you had to go
through again what happened to you but
it's important i think for people um to
realize the challenges that you faced at
the time and then also of course what
happened to you subsequently when you've
come back home it doesn't just end as
soon as you arrive home so thank you
very much indeed for talking us through
that thank you
yeah
thank you very much for having me